hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American mystery thriller
film called Glass Onion a Knives Out
mystery spoilers ahead watch out and
take care
[Music]
miles Braun co-founder of tech
conglomerate Alpha is an eccentric
billionaire who likes showing off his
wealth he has an annual tradition where
he invites his best friends to
extravagant locations and throws parties
for them even this time he has sent an
invitation in the form of a mystery box
the first one to receive it is Lionel
toussaints the chief scientist at Alpha
he is regarded as one of the smartest
Tech aficionados in town following this
the governor of Connecticut Clara de
bella and a fashion designer birdie J
also received the same boxes the final
friend from the group is Duke Cody a
YouTuber with millions of followers his
channel focuses on the importance of
men's rights before discuss the mystery
box in a group call and eventually find
the invitation from Miles inside later
we get to know that two more people have
been invited the first one is a
depressed looking woman whose name is
unknown while the second one is a
middle-aged man Benoit Blanc Google says
that he is the best detective in the
world best detective who sounds like
Foghorn Leghorn anyway in the next scene
the entire group arrives at a port in
Greece as per their invitations before
friends are happy to meet each other but
when they see the depressed woman show
up their expressions change the woman is
revealed to be Andy brand the other
co-founder of alpha she and Miles
started the company and took it to new
levels but for some reason she had to
abruptly leave on the other hand the
detective Benoit has never met any of
the members even miles he actually
doesn't know why he was invited
meanwhile a private yacht arrives to
escort them as does Ethan Hawke for some
reason Benoit is taken aback by the
luxuries around him he strikes up a
conversation with the tech genius Lionel
and learns that Miles has invited them
to play a murder mystery game after a
while they finally arrive at their
destination it is a huge island which
miles has rented for himself he is seen
playing guitar on the shore singing a
popular Beatles song like a proper Rich
[ __ ] when the group approaches him
miles wastes no time in showing off his
wealth he mentions that the guitar was
gifted to him by none other than the
lead singer of The Beatles Paul
McCartney miles greets all his friends
one one by one but as expected he has
taken aback to see Andy he is also
confused to see the detective there
nonetheless he introduces the island to
everyone revealing that it's just him
and them there are no helpers or maids
and the entire work is carried out by
Android robots you're not super rich
unless you don't employ anybody the
upper part of the Villa is made up of
glass and it looks like an onion miles
mentions that he has kept his favorite
sports car up there after the briefing
session he sends everyone to their
respective rooms and asks them to arrive
by the pool in the evening which are
assigned to them by their astrological
signs which is exactly the kind of Hocus
Pocus gibberish that wealthy douchebags
love and he asks them to arrive by the
pool in the evening later he takes
detective Benoit to The Glass Onion and
suddenly asks what are you doing here
perplexed the latter replies you sent me
an invitation miles asserts that he
didn't so Benoit takes out the
invitation card he found inside the
mystery box seeing this it finally Dawns
on Miles that someone from the group
sent their invitation card to Benoit
they probably wanted to have the best
detective in the world world for the
murder mystery game miles also likes
this idea so he officially invites
Benoit to his place in the next scene
everyone arrives at the pool to hang out
Kate Hudson signed on to this movie just
to show off she's still got a rock and
Bot at 43. the outcast Andy is also
there but everyone keeps mocking her
about something that she did in the past
meanwhile the YouTuber Cody reveals that
he has a gun on him when the others ask
why he brought it Cody simply replies
why not as all this is happening Benoit
can be seen eavesdropping on everyone's
conversation he also manages to Snoop
around the large Villa when no one is
watching later miles gathers everyone
and once again starts bragging about
himself he points to each one of his
friends and reveals how he has elevated
their careers miles made Lionel the head
scientist of alpha he campaigned for
Claire and won her the election he
promoted Cody's YouTube channel to make
it go viral and finally he introduced
birdie to the fashion industry while he
says all of this the four friends look
annoyed this makes it clear that they
just pretend to like Miles because
without his influence and money they are
nothing meanwhile Andy gets up and
starts giving a lecture she is
especially angry with her former
business partner miles who unfairly
ousted her and became the sole owner of
alpha she then turns on the rest calling
them greedy Liars however the four
quickly retaliate and say meaner things
to her this deeply affects Andy so she
storms away from the place that night
the real party finally begins everyone
is dressed in their fancy clothes and
Miles shows them around the place
surprisingly he has the iconic Mona Lisa
painting hung on his wall Benoit thinks
it's a copy as the real painting is in
the Louvre museum in Paris however miles
reveals that he bought it for an amount
that not even the French government
could refuse then he whips out a small
crystal-like substance which he calls
clear apparently this tiny substance has
the ability to power enormous appliances
without the omission of any harmful
gases miles mentions that clear is
manufactured using only sea water Benoit
asks if he can take a look at it so
miles tosses it towards him he calls it
the future which will help solve the
global energy crisis problem while
everyone looks in astonishment vinyl
appears to be angry he confronts miles
and asks for more time to test the
substance before it can go commercial
however to his dismay the wealthy
billionaire reveals that he has already
tested it in fact the very Island that
they are on is powered by a single gram
of clear that's how powerful it is
despite the Revelation Lionel is
skeptical about the plan as he believes
that the crystal is dangerous and
flammable after a while miles finally
starts his murder mystery game at first
he explains all the rules like how he
will be fictionally murdered by someone
and how there are Clues scattered all
across the house miles also reveals that
he hired James Cameron to prepare the
entire game which he believes is
extremely difficult but before he can
even finish Benoit using his Godlike
detective skills solves the entire case
he points to a bunch of Clues and
concludes that birdie is going to commit
the murder everyone in the room is
shocked and judging by Miles expression
it is confirmed that Benoit is correct
now that the game is over everyone
resorts to drinking and dancing
meanwhile miles takes Benoit to a glass
onion and asks why did you have to ruin
the party the latter replies that being
a detective he couldn't help it but just
then he notices a small note framed on
the wall on inquiring miles reveals that
it was the first blueprint of his
company Alpha which he had written on a
napkin he showed it to Andy and she
immediately liked the plan then together
they built Alpha and made it successful
saying all this Smiles mentions that he
misses those times when he and his
friends used to hang out in bars
although he was not rich he had friends
who genuinely cared for and loved him
but now they are only after his Fame and
money meanwhile downstairs the group is
again started with Andy they tell her to
go back home and never show herself
again Cody even mentions I don't regret
anything hearing this Andy becomes
enraged and walks away from there soon
miles arrives and encourages everyone to
continue with the party he promises to
have other games set up the next day
just then Cody gets a notification on
his phone and calls miles to check it
out when the latter sees it he appears
to be concerned nonetheless he maintains
his happy face and starts dancing with
the others shortly after Cody who is
having a drink suddenly starts choking
and drops to the floor everyone
surrounds him to check if he's fine but
Benoit reveals that he has died this
sends everyone into a state of panic and
they decide to leave immediately however
being a detective Benoit tells them to
stay right where they are he suspects
that Cody didn't die of natural causes
but he was murdered the whiskey he was
sipping on was probably poisoned as
benoise explaining his theory miles
suddenly notices his initials on the
glass Cody was drinking from this
reveals that the killer wanted to poison
him but Cody accidentally switched
glasses and drank from it realizing that
the Keller is still on the loose miles
goes into a state of panic to make
matters worse the group finds out that
Cody's gun is also missing how did he
not notice that the dude literally
carries it around in a speedo miles
pleads with Benoit for protection but
just then the lights go out it turns out
that Miles had scheduled the lights to
go out at this time hoping that the game
would become more interesting the
darkness Causes Chaos among the group
and they start running here and there
hear the thither most of them suspect
Andy to be the killer as she is the only
one having an agenda against them so
they start looking for her collectively
hoping to finish her off fortunately
Benoit gets to her first and briefs her
about the recent turn of events he also
tells her that they are very close to
finding out the truth this finally
reveals that the two have been working
together but before Andy can reach a
safe location someone shoots from a
nearby room Benoit is left speechless
and right before his eyes she passes
away soon after the others also arrive
and see the lifeless body of Andy
following this the movie goes into a
flashback Andy arrives at benoit's place
with her invitation card and hands it to
him she is wearing normal clothes which
is very unlike her in a foreign accent
she then introduces herself as Andy's
sister Helena she has come here all the
way from Alabama to avenge her sister's
death Helena explains that four days ago
Andy was found dead inside her garage
and all the signs pointed at her
committing the unthinkable however given
her history with Miles and the others
Helena
that she was murdered to prove her
Theory she brings out Andy's phone and
displays the last email she had sent
before her death in it she had attached
a picture of her holding a red envelope
and the message read I finally found it
I'm giving you all one last chance to
confess and he had sent the email to
Miles and the four friends but none of
them ever replied to her however when
Helena searched the entire house after
her sister's death she couldn't find the
envelope this means that whatever was
inside it was very important and someone
had to kill her to take it away Helena
knows that one of the five committed the
murder but she can't say who now she has
come to Benoit to ask for help as
according to google he is the best
detective in the world oh shucks prior
to her death Andy had already got the
invitation so she wants miles to go to
the private party in Greece and look for
the murderer the latter thinks for a
while and asks Helena if the public
knows about her sister's murder when she
says no miles asks her to come along
with him disguised as Andy as no one
apart from the murderer knows about her
truth if she plays along it will be
easier to identify the culprit Helena is
initially skeptical about the plan but
when Benoit asserts that it's for her
late sister she agrees the next night
before boarding a ship to Greece the two
meet at the seaside and plot their next
step Helena has a complete makeover and
she looks exactly like her sister she
has also been reading Andy's journal to
learn her mannerisms curious Benoit asks
Helena to read some parts of the journal
and the movie goes further into the past
it is revealed that a few years ago Andy
and the four were good friends they used
to hang out at a bar and be happy at the
smallest of things life was simple but
difficult at the time then one day Andy
introduced her friend miles to all of
them look at this guy's Choice haircut
he was a curious guy who had a lot of
ideas and opinions slowly he became
close to everyone and they accepted him
into their group one evening Andy had a
remarkable idea it was about starting a
tech company with the most advanced yet
cheapest products she even wrote down
her idea on a piece of napkin which
miles approved of immediately the two
then became partners and established
Alpha which went on to become one of the
largest tech corporations in the world
but like every other establishment this
one was not short of problems miles
wanted to use a new element AKA clear to
power up factories but Andy was against
it she even threatened to leave the
company and take half the shares if it
was the only way to stop him from
investing in clear soon the matter went
to court both sides gave their
statements and it all boiled down to who
was the real owner of alpha Andy being
the rightful owner said that she first
came up with the idea and even wrote it
down on a piece of napkin the judge
asked her to show proof but
unfortunately Andy had lost the note so
she asked her friends Claire birdie Cody
and Lionel to vouch for her however to
her astonishment they lied and took
miles aside the latter had even managed
to create a fake note which eventually
won the case in his favor in this way
Andy was kicked out of her own company
and deceived by her own France desperate
for Revenge she searched her entire
house and finally found the note then
she put it inside an envelope click the
picture with it and sent it to her
ex-friends following this the movie Fast
forwards to the time Helen and Benoit
arrived on the islands on the day when
Andy AKA Helena stormed off after having
an argument at the pool she was followed
by Claire and Cody Helen asked why they
didn't reply to her email to which
Claire revealed that she couldn't
because she is a politician one wrong
move would end her career however she
along with the others had come to her
house and banged on the door for hours
when no one responded they laughed Cody
then revealed that he was the first one
to come and on the way he almost got
into an accident next the movie forwards
to the scene where the party had just
started Helena once again argues with
the group and goes out but her real plan
was to check their rooms for the Red
Envelope she spent hours and turned
every room upside down but couldn't find
it suddenly the lights went out and when
she rushed outside she met Benoit this
is when she was shot dead by an unknown
assailant but surprisingly after a few
seconds she miraculously woke up it
turns out the journal she was carrying
saved her from the bullet Benoit was
relieved to see her life but he also had
an idea in mind he wanted her to keep
playing dead so that she could get
enough time to find the envelope Helena
obliged and to make the scene more
convincing Benoit applied some hot sauce
on her face once everyone left she
quickly rushed to the one place she
hadn't searched the Glass Onion luckily
her gas turned out to be correct and she
found the envelope behind a wall back in
the present Benoit gathers everyone and
explains that he finally knows who the
real killer is it is none other than the
billionaire miles just some hours ago
the police found Andy's dead body and
the News quickly circulated Cody being a
YouTuber got to know of this so he
started blackmailing miles it turns out
when Cody was on his way to Andy's house
that day he had come across miles and
almost crashed into his car this means
that the cunning billionaire had already
killed Andy and taken the envelope
before any of them even arrived
unfortunately before Cody could make use
of this information miles poisoned him
to death he even switched their glasses
to divert the attention from himself
following this miles took his gun and
killed Helena as she was getting
dangerously close to finding out the
truth herself he had known that she was
an imposter all along but decided to
remain silent just then Helena also
arrives with the note in her hand
shocking everyone she then confronts
miles and taunts him that he'll soon be
behind bars but just then the latter
puts fire to her note and burns it down
with this the final piece of evidence of
their whole mission is erased Helena
asks the rest of the group if they will
vouch for her but no one agrees after
all that has happened they still support
miles distraught Benoit leaves the room
but not before handing the clear crystal
to Helen surprisingly this reinvigorates
her and she starts smashing everything
in the room miles assumes that she's
simply angry so he doesn't try to stop
her but to his horror Helena lights fire
to the place she then throws the clear
crystal inside of it causing the Glass
Onion to explode sadly the iconic Mona
Lisa painting also burns down
as a result the group finally realizes
that what miles is doing is wrong he is
a terrorist who only cares about himself
and his Fame not the safety of others
hence they agree to support Helena and
put miles behind bars the billionaire is
enraged and he tries to persuade his
friends by offering them money but this
time they don't listen in the final
scene a Victorious Helena approaches
Benoit and thanks him for everything
don't mention it little doll then as
they look at each other a boat can be
seen in the dead of the night probably
to pick them up well I say a mystery I
say a mystery mystery is solved
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching